طبعا في ظل الانقطاع التام للسولار وفي ظل
استمرار العدوان الاسرائيلي على قطع غزه
لليوم الاربعين يعني لا لا يتوفر لدينا
الان الرار الكميه الموجوده طرفنا في
محافظه الشمال تقريبا لا لا تكفي لمده 48
ساعه بالكاد تكفي لمده 48 ساعه وسيتوقف
عمل الدفاع المدني انما يتوفر لدينا كميه
من السر يعني في حال توقف الدفاع المدني
بشكل كامل لا سمح الله ستكون هناك كارثه
كارثه كبيره يعني انا اريد ان يتخيل
العالم كيف سيكون المشه عندما يكون هناك
حرائق حولنا او في المكان لا نستطيع تحريك
مركبه اطفاء لاطفاء الحريق يعني لا اتخيل
المشهد كيف سيكون المشهد ولكن سيكون مشهد
كارثي ومر ناشد كافه المؤسسات الدوليه
وكافه دول العالم وكافه الاحرار في العالم
لضروره الضغط على الاحتلال لادخال السولار
وادخال الامكانيات التي يستطيع التي
يحتاجها الدفاع المدني ليستطيع تقديم
الخدمه واستمرار تقديم الخدمه الاغاثه
والانسانيه
للمواطنين
ه